un regard qui vous transpercent des
personnages forts qui vous dévisagent
ses collages sont l'oeuvre de l'une des
neuf artistes exposés à langer poésie
délicate aux inspirations asiatiques ou
au contraire allégorie engagé de l'homme
et la nature les visiteurs sont séduits
la salle est très belle donc beaucoup
beaucoup d'artistes et toujours c'est
toujours sympa à l'ensemble me plaît
beaucoup j'ai bien aimé les différents
tableaux celui que je préfère c'est
celui ci oui c'est un ressenti un coup
de coeur trouve que c'est pas des choses
qu'on voit partout
des oeuvres originales et à plus d'un
titre les artistes choisis pour
l'exposition nouvelles donnes n'ont
presque pas exposer voire pas du tout à
langer c'est l'occasion d'une première
rencontre avec le public
je travaille essentiellement sur
l'humain sur les émotions et donc quand
quand je crée j'aime traversée par
certaines émotions et du coup le fait
d'exposer
me dis que je vais rencontrer des
personnes chez qui je vais peut-être
provoqué quelque chose une sensibilité
particulière une émotion particulière et
cette rencontre là en fait m'intéresse
beaucoup
partager leurs émotions et pas seulement
à travers leurs oeuvres les artistes
sont présents à tour de rôle sur
l'exposition j'aime beaucoup
entendre les la façon dont ils reçoivent
en fait le message que j'ai acheté deux
de transmettre et
donc voilà c'est des discussions qui
sont assez plaisante
et l'une d'entre eux pourraient même
venir finir son tableau sous vos yeux
pour les rencontrer et découvrir leurs
créations vous avez jusqu'au 13 février